did you guys even want to act when he
first started were you acting
no
I did want to write but we won it wasn't
uh no one from our town did like it
wasn't a thing which whichever I never
saw it as a viable option of
of a career and so much so the the Drama
teacher at our school said don't take
drama for your essentially High School
level because you won't have a career in
it so I had great Delight going back to
him after that summer and be like well
do you know nothing how about this I
actually I actually told that story when
we we did um one of the theme park rides
have been open at Universal in Florida
and I told that story and a couple of
weeks later I had a tweet from a a kid
who went to my who goes to my former
school and said this video has now been
banned from being shown in class because
everybody keeps playing it when said
teacher was sick like given his advice